Spider-Man kills Venom and it's amazing
check this out so in secret Wars 2015
Marvel released this story called
Spider-Man renew your vows and in this
story it turned out there was a crazy
villain named Regent who was running
around capturing all the superheroes and
all the super villains and taking their
powers The Avengers all band together to
defeat this guy and Spider-Man's
supposed to join them but in that moment
Venom attacks Spider-Man's family so
having to choose between the two
Spider-Man abandons the Avengers and
goes to fight Venom when he gets there a
great big huge conflict breaks out the
building catches on fire the whole thing
starts to collapse and is all falling on
Eddie Brock AKA Venom now as he's laying
there and basically burning he begs
Spider-Man for help but Peter Parker
thinks about it for a minute and
realizes Venom will never stop attacking
his family so instead of rescuing him
Spider-Man lets Venom burn alive make
sure you guys check the comments for the
link to the whole video